oh god
well i walked in and i saw a raised dead
body on admin mr beast was behind me so
i don't think it's him
this video is sponsored by wollon
download it right now it's available for
ios and android it's a game that lets
you join events
right now i've joined the sleeper hollow
event if i get
200 pumpkins i will get an iphone 12
mini
it's kind of cool actually it's raining
outside and it's raining in the game i'm
not going outside though
so this is how it works yeah there you
are it's kind of cool actually all right
the iphone 12 is mine mini so yeah you
can walk around
outside get tokens based on where you
live they will spawn around you nearby
there's different events in walden right
now there's also an armani watch event
where you need to get 250 all right i'm
gonna go outside and get some i need
[Music]
extra
so what are you waiting for use the link
in the description and enter my referral
code when you sign up
pewdiepie for wallen so yeah thank you
allen for sponsoring this video
use the link in the description
[Music]
all right we're good to go it's time
dude i'm so glad you're here felix
likewise seeing the boys
i was so scared that you weren't
actually going to join because i was
like wait did he say he's coming or not
oh you were right sorry well i said it
was coming did i did i not you're like
sounds cool
[Laughter]
yes that was cool i'm in that's it
that's a written contrast
it doesn't get more formal than that
right
all right we're playing among us that's
right and i'm not allowed to look at the
chat
because i'm supposed to figure out who
it is taking baby steps here yeah
let's check admin that's always good to
start right so anyone pops off on the
left you know they've been
the plan is to stay alive viking style
as i was done
people don't know this it has not been
recognized for whatever reason
i am the best among us player just watch
this grease but yeah jimmy would never
kill me yeah what's up jimmy you want to
do gas with me
yeah yeah you like that you do it too
hey look
our pets can be friends that's so cute
yeah where do you want to go jimmy yeah
you're gonna go you just came from there
let me know let's go here
yeah yeah yeah
the lights let's just go no no no let's
go get it
it's dark
toast you saw the vents open right yeah
yo we can see our faces catch up too
that's so cool so the body was in the
bottom left it was rhyme styles body
uh me and toast were chilling so it's
not him for sure
yeah we saw the vents open where's the
body bottom left by the
uh i have something that might be
helpful
maybe no actually i don't know okay it's
just me and me and beast was chilling in
like
the right side of yeah we were in the
middle almost that entire time
it wasn't jack as well and uh
and corpse was the last person we saw
come from left
then and the bodies on the left side so
that would make
that would where did you where did you
come from cars so you come from left or
right
into electrical i went from the top oh i
appreciate i came to the right
that might check out and confirm he was
with me okay okay
but just ignore me then leave so it was
bobby and ray
yeah choke me corpse i'm sorry i'm an
electrical and i went up through
cafeteria
go do asteroids and i saw her on my way
i guess it's no one
maybe they just like fell over wait a
minute
someone is lying then um
[Music]
wait there's a war going on here this is
like twilight oh bobby
you guys are insane
i think you asked us to choke you bobby
yeah you asked for it oh that's oh
technically true all right mr bees yeah
marinate me yeah let's go [ __ ] the
oxygen
all right you do the oxygen yeah are you
not gonna do it
why wasn't you not doing it
wait in front of everyone um oh
no so all right it's valkyrie
valkyrie yeah just watched her murder
pewdiepie yeah
not have killed everyone like that well
you did technically
i think that she did
[Laughter]
wow
[Music]
i know that was insane i didn't even do
anything i never tried that again
no matter how hard i try oh imposter
what just kidding
oh no let's go with mr beast
bobby what are you doing here does the
task not move anymore
oh okay there's a moving beta gotcha oh
god bobby you got to do something mae
everyone's sticking together what do i
do what's the
the dream team me and bobby this is what
i wanted all along
stack bobby killed anyone oh everyone's
alive everyone's sticking together
oh we got electrical is security okay
[Music]
i think someone might have actually just
vented out i
have a theory is anybody new to this no
because
there's only one kill after like what
two minutes to be fair that's a good
point we've been together so
i think a lot of people are grouping i
have a theory that everyone's afraid of
dying first
yes i died first last round soul
all right i'm gonna run off on my own so
if the killer wants to kill me go ahead
um i won't feel bad at all see you there
psych you know jack why didn't you hop
on the vent with me
i didn't know what you were doing and
scared the show oh i'm sorry i was uh
nothing ignore that so we're skipping
well the killer's on the left side
wink everyone's sticking together oh i
forgot i have sabotage
okay can't kill jimmy
wait i have stuff to do here oh wait so
we do see the taskbar after you drown
that's kind of cool okay don't kill
jimmy
uh are we having a sabotage no
oh so the keys body is a navigation
all the way on the right okay a green
green white purple red
we're in electrical oh god you are
becoming toast oh no
she must be right then she must be right
if she read out colors
this happened uh during lights because
we left her
there as light was being called bobby
okay
first around i saw you pretend to do
bottom o2
was that just all right
there we go oh no
there's no way bobby got it two times in
a row right
literally i was just in reactor i was
doing the hand print i went to go check
cameras and the body got discovered
there was no reaction where you scanned
the hand where you go up
oh
oh you guys actually killed them i
thought we were going to let them oh
we all have this one yeah
oh god i think toast is on to me
oh god
well i walked in and i saw a raised dead
body on admin
mr beast was behind me so i don't think
it's him okay yeah we just walked into
where that card scanner is
and the the report thing popped up on my
screen jack did you go on the cameras
too
yep me and best friend were so stoking
it out you saw what i saw right
oh no i didn't i i was the panel was
coming off as the audio sign so i didn't
actually see anything
oh um well uh there was a there's a
camera outside of admin
[Music]
and what'd you see lay it down cycuno
well
um someone walked in with ray and uh
ray didn't walk out i don't want to
accuse anyone um
but but i mean it's it's it was uh
it was feeling i was like who knows
white feelings i mean it's the only one
left
uh that's impossible it's impossible
because uh i'll tell you what happened
okay i went to the cafeteria
into med bay and that's where the body
was reported
the body wasn't in bed body wasn't in
bed no no that's when the body was
reported
[Music]
i'm pretty sure i saw him i think um how
sherry are you i don't get it
sure you're going to have to convict
psycho yeah we need harder i mean i i i
definitely saw him but i don't want to
it sounds like he's an impostor throwing
around sus to see
the one that wanted to skip last time
i just voted i just voted to skip for
for for uh bobby because i didn't want
him
to just get because he did skip on bobby
you admitted to being an imposter
well that's just because i was trying to
be i didn't want to wait no
guys there's kind of rude excuse i don't
know
thank you toast thanks for sparing my
life
what do i do here should i have voted
sakuna there yeah but then it's obvious
it's me
uh how do i get out of here
oh no did he see me i found jack's body
and bottom left reactor
oh wait wait hold up hold up i was just
sitting on camera let me process what i
was seeing
i think yeah i saw you on cams yeah no i
think it was you poods
like you went south with them and then
you magically came up out of reactor
you vented oh wait i tell you no i
didn't magically come up
anywhere what the [ __ ] someone went down
there with them were you not the one
no who who went down with jack wait
i wasn't toast in reactor i was in
reactor yes
this body is on bottom left engine i was
just saying
you know i need to pay attention either
cycle or toes
if you think i don't want to get plain i
trust your i
think it's felix i'm pretty certain i
saw him walk down at the vent up it's so
ironic cause i was just saying
what do you think it is um well i i was
trying to be polite earlier but
but after you killed me yeah say it as
it is what
no no say it's it's it's it's def it's
felix
okay yeah i think all right it's my time
to go guys it's been real
i'm sorry it's all right you're gonna
regret it we can't let him get away with
killing gonna feel so
bad
oh but you let him get away with it when
he kills me huh
well thank you i'll play guys
i've never seen an imposter fake reactor
and o2 before
so you know what when they weren't even
on that was somebody
choked me up what the [ __ ]
okay so what oh
i'm getting screwed screw the giveaways
everyone be quiet everyone be quiet this
is the moment
we all waited for it let's do this i
can't mess this up
oh hell yeah we're gonna kill him
someone had to do with you
oh no okay it was my time
i'm sorry okay we got her out done
she's done so we gotta keep bobby online
okay you guys you guys you can you can't
just happen
you can't keep killing pokey over and
over again okay so
for real it's me pokey rhyme style and
pew
oxygen where was the body uh on the
oxygen on the right side
and they were three stacked and one of
them killed pokey
i think it's dino awful what it's rhyme
sorry
oh yeah oh the reason why i think it's
rhyme style is because i've played with
rhyme style many a time before and i'm
using inside information
i don't know how to play this where do
you go
ah
i'm really really sorry i thought it was
you dude
uh where was the body it's in reactor
is that the thing beside the security
cameras yeah
oh jack you found it okay well i guess
he's yeah so it's pewds right
i i didn't even answer i didn't even end
the reactor you were with me
please
this could be a vent by toast either
what does all of our guts say wait so
let let's do the math
if there's only one person left or if
there's two people left and we pick the
wrong one we lose right
that's correct yes but that also sounds
like a really great like
like you know beast is just like i have
no idea what i'm doing just killed
nothing
no i'm trying to just put that on the
table like if if it is
toast and we pick pewds or if it's fused
and we pick toast like why do you keep
throwing me out i don't [ __ ]
get it so for the people weren't you
there when they stacked killed isn't
that yeah the pokey killer yeah but it
could have been toasted
style if we play it safe we vote felix
here and we for sure yeah
i already did it mommy why would you say
jack wait jack
tell them the reason i didn't work with
the tv prize because i didn't even end
the reaction and then he got off
you're gonna lose if we would have the
wrong one here
anymore well the thing is i joined you
outside of cams and we were in that
hallway and you were kind of hovering
around and i thought oh you might kill
me yeah but
i thought yeah there's a body in the
reactor and you're on cooldown but
someone must have vented in there that's
literally the only i mean
that is also highly possible yeah i'm
serious
it has to be toast then or is it
dudes and beasts it's got to be felix
right
i don't know
oh no gg
[Applause]
do hey like that sneaky line at the end
i was like oh yeah you [ __ ] my head
too much
i didn't do that kill so he made it easy
to lie there jack flawless victory field
let's go jim felix and have him yell at
me
oh my god
[Music]